so then if you get the okay on the
outline yes and what's day one of pages
like Dave one of pages is and I'll just
give you an example because last Monday
I turned in a new assignment so day one
of pages is like starting a new job
except it's at my office you know it's
the same familiar surroundings but it's
starting a new job and luckily there
wasn't a great amount of time between me
finishing the treatment and and the
company saying go because I like it when
it's fresh still that I can jump right
on rather than this you know there's a
momentum that's really important about
things like that and so I sit down and
today's my first day writing and I look
at my calendar and I know that I have
thirty days and so I do the math and I
divide up the days and I say okay I
should and I leave myself about a three
or four days at the end of you know I'm
not just gonna say fade out the end and
turn in the script I want to look it
over I want to fix things I want to
polish it but I don't want to be doing
that as I'm writing it because I can't
do that I have to push forward and
that's why a lot of times in the one I
just turned in I reread it from start to
finish and I was like oh but I didn't
revisit it for almost a month ago right
because I started and I was like it's
done that's not bad you know I started
having to feel that I didn't quite
remember if this was good or bad and
that there's some days and I think this
is good writing and there's other days
I'm like this is not good but I always
have my backup guide is my treatment
that I've worked on so there I'm not
just left hanging in the wind you know
but I did did get into a point and it
took a few days that I had about a five
or six page gap in the story where I was
gonna come up short you know and I have
a mandate about how many pages the
script has to be and I was like how did
I come up short and I find this too
sometimes when I consult on people's
treatments I said you don't have enough
story to facilitate a hundred pages here
you think you do but you know then they
put into a half a page description and I
can break that down and say in an actual
page of script that's going to be about
half a page you know that's not this
needs to be four or five pages of a
sequence you know what I mean so they
come up short many times so I worked
through that but like I said I had my
treatment to to fall back on and they
knew these characters so if I just let
the characters run you know they're
gonna you know you're there I'm gonna
follow them they're not gonna follow me
I'm just gonna you know I mean I think
you know when when you know your
characters you follow them and let them
run off and say wait and say I got it
you know and so that was that was the
first day and I so I was up about three
pages a day
which is a luxury but I've also worked
on scripts or I had to do eight to ten
pages a day and I mean if you miss a day
and you can't miss a day and there's you
know there's things in life that
happened and a lot of stuff goes on but
but it's a day job I mean it's a day or
a night job and I'm lucky that I can
push my schedule where my day can start
at three o'clock and go till late you
know I mean I can shift it which is good
and that a few years ago I was working
on an assignment and that really messed
me up because I was I was worried more
about how I was starting my day so late
and I said why don't you just relax and
and and accept the fact that your day
starts at two o'clock and I did and you
know what it was great once I let go of
that I was productive for the next you
know eight hours so you know shifting
that the time helps but again I have I
don't say the luxury but that is my job
to do that to work all day on the script
and so I better be doing that you know
sure you trust yourself more now maybe
because in the beginning maybe it's
scary because you're like because you
don't know without the experience of
writing multiple screenplays and being
you know muddied in the trenches and do
you know fail you don't know you your
abilities and so you know I'm not overly
confident but I know what I can do so I
said okay and then I met the deadline
for this last job and I had three or
four days left over and so that was a
luxury to be just now I can and it felt
great the night before it was due I
earned in you know
email the script and so that morning the
producer would get up and sure enough
you know here it is just like I said you
know and and and you always have to be
building your integrity constantly and
they don't they don't want to have to
worry about you the one that's that
shooting now a film that I have shooting
in Los Angeles the producer is doing
other movies at the same time and he
didn't want to have to worry about me
you know check up all if I'm doing the
job and all you know and that's a good
place to be because you don't have to
worry about me you know I you know and
so you only you only do that by you know
your experiences when you turn in one
job and work with somebody they go okay
you turn another do it now that's just
the norm your integrity is built there
you know which is which is also vital
for any screenwriting career is your
professionalism in your integrity so in
the beginning when you would start let's
say a new script once you receive the
outline would you do like 8:00 a.m. and
the coffee's there and you're okay this
is it the clock's ticking or I mean how
were you able to finally say you know
what I'm better at two o'clock I know
myself I know how I need to have lunch
first I need to do all these different
pages clear my mind breaks but also the
day gets away you know and that's not
good either and so I'm I don't have to
you know eight o'clock being okay I got
to go you know but you know I ease into
the morning and then start work and you
know I mean three pages a day is a
luxury but you know eight or ten that
were those are rough days you know and
some days you're not as productive and
you don't meet that deadline and but
other days you you explode into twelve
pages you know how did that happen so it
kind of evens out but but if you're
doing fewer pages a day you know you
know you only have so much time that's
why I say when writers are doing their
spec set your own self-imposed deadline
don't let it be open-ended where you
know oh yeah I was working on this last
year and Christmas came but you know
because you're gonna need that training
you know and even while you're working
in it with experience it's still
difficult you got to stand because
you're your own boss no one's no one's
calling me saying are you working today
and the day goes on and then you know I
mean you got to really stay on it and
realize there's a lot of self work I
mean it's like you're your own boss and
it's good in one way people say oh I
would love to do that but with that
comes a lot of responsibility you know
in keeping to that at that point and
with that are you ever saying to
yourself okay now it's time to turn off
because there is a fear that runs in
with being your own boss where yeah what
if I don't end in so but are there four
points where you say you know what I
need to stop now yes I usually when I
feel that it was Bennet it's been a good
day of writing there'll be a point I
forgot which writer said this the famous
writer that you know leave something
just leave something more tomorrow to
come back to you know and I always look
at my characters like they're waiting
going okay you know we were just at us
at the end of the cliff what are we uh
we gotta wait till tomorrow you know
don't have him jump the cliff and then
go to bed you know so when I would
finish a day's work it would feel good
to clock out so to speak at six o'clock
where I go I'm done you know but I also
knew that if I was behind it in trouble
I have the rest of the night you know
whatever needs to be done and but I
would prefer not to do that and also
weekends to a lot of people so you know
screenwriters don't always get weekends
off and so my friends who have day jobs
I go you work Monday through Friday I
work you know sometimes my weekends or
you know Monday and Tuesday you know
Saturday I have to hit the bricks you
know and do the work and that's okay but
they're like you know they're you know
it's just what happens and it's fine but
but they behave the ability to shift the
schedule is is one of the things that I
enjoy and also the ability to write
anywhere in the world last year I was in
Italy for six weeks and I wrote I wrote
a job that I got in Los Angeles so
producer didn't care where I was we
communicated but that was part of the
initial attraction of being a writer was
that you didn't need a big crew and you
didn't need all these you know spend two
years on a project that you could be
in a cafe somewhere you know in an
italian island writing a movie nice so
that that but you also bottom line is
you have to write and stick to a
schedule I mean that's just that's vital
that would be very distracting it is I
thought it would be I thought it would
be you know I'm inside him like ho but
there's all this stuff outside that I
should do Vatican I want to see the
Vatican yeah but you get over that when
you're like okay I have to work you know
that helped me to go there so yeah you
know I mean it's true yeah for six weeks
so Who am I to complain sure sure
you